the
federal housing agencies so fhfa extends
cover 19 reo eviction moratorium
through september 30th 2021 on friday
the fhfa
announced that fannie mae and freddie
mac the enterprises are extending the
moratorium on single-family real
estate-owned reo's evictions until
september 30th the re-eviction
moratorium applies to prop properties
that have been acquired by an enterprise
through foreclosure or deed and lieu
of foreclosure transactions the current
moratorium was set to expire july 31st
2021 the pandemic continues to have an
outsized impact on the ability of
americans to meet their monthly rental
mortgage payments today's extension of
the eviction moratorium
protect particularly vulnerable
americans who otherwise
would be at risk of losing a place to
live said acting director sandra
thompson
the re-eviction moratorium is just the
latest step fhfa has taken to benefit
homeowner renters and mortgage
market during the pandemic so this is
happening yesterday bernie sanders aoc
were out there marching i think in dc
talking about the fact that we should
extend this
there's arguments on both sides what are
your thoughts on this so listen you want
to be
humanitarian and these are properties
that are owned by the fhfa so
it's it's it's not the same as if you
have some of these eviction moratoriums
that people
are faced with who are landlords and you
can see both sides of it you certainly
want to be humanitarian in the landlord
side
but you definitely want to also try and
be somewhat sympathetic to the
to the person to the person who's being
evicted i mean
both sides you could definitely see it
because a lot of people who are
landlords aren't necessarily large
corporations they're just people that
are
hard-working middle-class people they
put theirs they purchase a home because
they'd like to these are landlords
landlords
yeah you know now in this particular
case it's the fhfa
so this is a government agency here but
the moratorium that's currently in
effect for renters is something that
you want to be humanitarian sympathetic
but you also need to think about
what's that landlord going through
that's just an individual that's
purchasing that's purchased that home
and now is
is faced with somebody living there in
their home where we at right now with
that where are we at right now with that
because if this is fhfa
it's supposed to be the end of august
that that that's been posted that's
going to be
yeah but i think that you know given
this delta variant has now
become more prevalent there's a good
chance that that gets so here's a
problem i have with that the problem i
have with it is the fact that
states were given 45 billion dollars
okay to help tenants and landlords
45 billion dollars to help tenants and
landlords okay
you know according to new york times
story that came out yesterday what
percentage of that 45 billion has been
given to tenants and landlords
do you know what percentage of 45
billion less than 20. seven percent
so here's my check and by the way this
is new york times we're not talking new
york
post right it's new york times writing
this so this is a new york post
which some may say it's a conservative
paper so if 45 billion has been given to
states
to give to tenants and landlords and
that money hasn't gone to them
and you want to extend you can't tell me
to extend it if you're
hanging on to the money that you're
supposed to help me out to
if you give me the money i'll sit there
and say okay fine but if you're hanging
on to the money and only giving seven
percent of the 45 billion which is only
three
billion dollars what are you going to do
with this what's their justification
what's their job
because they can't what are you going to
tell them you're going to write a
negative review on yelp
you're going to go out there and yell
and there's some people that would good
luck with the government nobody go to a
government place and say you're going to
write a negative review on
something and see what they tell you
that money's not coming to you so in a
situation like this at what point do you
say
listen you guys got to figure something
out i can't keep extending this
uh i think the unemployment if you
remember the unemployment during obama
it kept extending you know six months
and it won nine months and then it went
12 months and it kept going extinct
yeah it was a long time that it kept
going it was nearly you know 24 months
is where it got to i think 99 weeks was
the number right and
the moment you stopped unemployment
benefits guess what happened to people
the moment you stopped back to work you
know there's something interesting about
that i know it's one of the stories you
want to cover but
this is a really interesting thing right
now there's 9.2 million job openings
and people are pointing to that and the
fed's pointing to that this kind of lead
us into the fed as well
but the fed's saying you know we're not
seeing maximum employment well if you're
paying people 18
an hour to stay home guess what they're
going to stay home but there's an
interesting phenomenon that takes place
so half the states roughly have now said
we're going to end this additional
benefit
and what they've seen is something
that's fascinating the number of job
creations goes up but so does the
unemployment rate
so people are scratching their heads and
they pointed at employer and said oh
it's not really a benefit
well what happens is is when you don't
look for a job for four weeks
you are now a discouraged worker so you
literally do not get counted
as unemployed as soon as you come off
that you start looking for a job
you start off as unemployed but so your
unemployment numbers worsen initially
but you at the same time have some of
those people who find jobs
so if you have 10 people go back five
found a job
now you have five people that are
counted as unemployed it actually makes
the unemployment
numbers look worse while jobs are being
created look better
but it depends on what side you're on
what you want to point to you always
look you know you always find what
you're looking for so if you point to
job creations that things are good
but eventually as these people then come
back to
finding a job and getting a job the
unemployment numbers should come down
so labor day we're supposed to see an
end to this additional benefit
so i'd imagine you'll probably see the
unemployment rate in september and maybe
in
october get worse while jobs are created
but then it should start to catch up and
you should
see it going past september i i
you know the delta variant is something
that people are very concerned about you
know everybody's talking about
now masks indoors and this and that and
i think facebook today said they're
requiring all employees whether you're
vaccinated or not to have a mascot
don't really quite understand that um
but it's something that
individuals are are going to be faced
with now going back to work or child
care based on this and it might it might
kick the can down the road it might
prolong it so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you